We've now reached
the end of this course.
We began with the nature and
problems of our healthcare system and
the key role that chronic disease plays.
We made the case for
digital records and data sharing.
And we learned what the Federal
Government is doing to encourage their
adoption.
We examined the key
underlying technologies and
looked at how they're being used in
actual systems and tools for providers,
patients, population and
public health, and clinical research.
We explored in more detail how data
can be aggregated for analysis.
And we concluded with a number of
exciting examples of the results that
can be achieved.
We're only at the beginning
of a long journey.
It's my hope that this course will
encourage you to come along and
be part of a generation that actually
achieves the long held dream of
transforming healthcare
through health informatics.
Please don't hesitate to
ask me if I can help.
Good-bye, I wish you well.